joining us now with more is Fox News
contributor Sarah Carter and the author
of witch-hunt Fox News legal analyst
Gregg Jarrett thank you both for joining
me tonight I know we're going to get
right down to the heart of what all of
this is what we just listen to is just
absolutely awful Craig let me start with
you because when you see a number of
headlines here after all of this stuff
with the impeachment about how it was
urgent and it kept the Republicans from
being able to do certain things because
it time was short because yet isn't bad
horrible man in the White House we ought
to be stopped suddenly now it's like oh
you know we got all the time in the
world media's arguing about how this is
a genius strategy what is your take on
it well first of all nobody takes
Richard painters seriously which is why
he's on MSNBC and CNN this is the guy
who sued Trump three days after he took
office
so he's utterly irrelevant and a joke
but as to your question you know the
framers never envisioned a stunt pulled
by a Speaker of the House like Nancy
Pelosi holding on to articles of
impeachment two decades ago it was sent
over immediately within minutes there
was a vote to convey and transmit it the
Constitution is actually silent about
that it doesn't say that the Senate has
to wait until it's transmitted it's
simply a Senate rule Mitch McConnell
shouldn't be subjecting himself to the
extortion of Nancy Pelosi he can
beginning in January simply alter the
rule or eliminate it entirely and set a
date for an impeachment trial Pelosi
wants to deprive Trump of sort of a
sixth amendment right yes it's not a
criminal trial but the principle applies
could confronting your accuser he's
entitled to a trial he's entitled to an
acquittal if that's what the
supermajority de sauver majority would
decide you have to have a supermajority
to remove him well in this of course
Sarah we've seen this before it's in
their nature to deny due process to
someone they accuse you'll think of
justice Kavanagh months and weeks of
just trying to destroy that man's
character and then just throwing him out
right that that was done they've
accomplished that it looks like they
want to accomplish the same thing
here is that your sense you if some
people think about Pelosi is serious and
she really wants fairness in in the
Senate when she didn't of course afford
that to the president what's your take
on her real agenda and what the impact
will be ultimately on the Democrats well
in my opinion Tammy the real agenda here
is that Nancy Pelosi never wanted to do
this to begin with she knows it's
political suicide and the only thing she
can do is actually hold on to these
papers to not move the impeachment
forward in the Senate she's struggling I
mean she was basically taken hostage by
radicals in her own party she tried to
talk them out of it in the beginning
then she believed Adam Schiff and
believed that he had promised her there
was they were going to have all this
evidence in the house hearings that they
were going to prove that the president
is impeachable and that they were going
to have all of this evidence and they
had no evidence they had nothing at all
so what happened was all the sudden we
have a very partisan straight down the
middle impeachment in the House Nancy
Pelosi knows that if she takes it to the
Senate it's not going to be good for the
Democrats the only thing she can do
right now is hold on to those articles
of impeachment and by the way another
point here a lot of people are trying to
make out on the Democrat side and even
Jennifer Rubin with the Washington Post
like she is some kind of genius for
doing this this was her only option it's
not like she thought about this before
she went into it she just has no other
way out of this well is if she's gonna
play her cards yeah in fact perhaps this
was the plan from the start ultimately
because it has been a scheme and they
really have not they haven't cared about
the impact on the country but Greg
there's also this presumption it seems
from the Democrats that the Republicans
will allow this to continue maybe they
do think we've seen the president's
numbers go up we've seen the opposition
to it to impeachment go up as well but
isn't it proper because if they don't
but there's nothing in the Constitution
that says they have to do this as you've
noted and they could change the rule
easily should we expect them to do that
would it be better for them to do that
or would this charade continue to be
exposed by letting it sit well the
choice is too
old Mitch McConnell can say well if
you're not going to send them over I
don't care we're not it we're not going
to deal with it Nancy Pelosi though
could then use it as a cudgel to hit
Trump over the head at every tad things
to it yes simply change the rule hold a
trial do it and do it on their own terms
you know the Constitution doesn't say
the sole power to trial impeachments
with the consent and advice of Nancy
Pelosi it doesn't say it and this I
think that that's the that's the big
deal Sarah is that in fact and this
isn't what all of this is politics we
know this in and and the Republicans are
concerned about what's happening here
but we as the citizens are concerned
about how the Constitution is being
shredded at this point and made a
mockery of if the Republicans went ahead
and they know what the articles of
impeachment are they've seen what the
dynamic is do you think that that would
be in the long run no president Trump of
course would be exonerated do you think
that is the best way to go or do you
think again there's the argument that
America should see the Democrats for
what they are look in my personal
opinion I think America has already seen
the Democrats for what they are the
American people don't want to put up
with this we've seen the numbers turn in
president Trump's favor of course if
Mitch McConnell makes that decision if
they make the decision to move with a
fast and speedy trial and this
impeachment charade that's going to be
their prerogative in their choice but I
think right now the Democrats are
showing the public who they really are
and they will continue to show that Tami
they really have nowhere to go here they
don't have anybody in their party come
2020 that stands out as a figure that
can even challenge President Trump right
now and they know it and they know this
and this is driving them mad so this is
basically all they have this is kind of
like their hoorah their advertisement
their way of raising funds so I don't
think if it goes either way either way
this goes it's not going to be good for
them in the end so I think it's a
win-win for Republican or the real
tragedy is that the bar has now been set
so low for impeachment by Nancy Pelosi
and Adam Schiff and Jerry Nadler any
perceived defenses now impeachable and
it will
extend in perpetuity more and more
impeachments by Democrats
unless Republicans vote Democrats out of
office they lose control of the house
and Nancy Pelosi loses their job
otherwise we're going to see multiple
impeachments down the road if there is
not a dramatic response by the people
where where the final word it will send
I think a signal that all of this has
been acceptable and it's not just a
difference in politics we all can
disagree this has been a wanton
disregard for the impact not just on our
system but on the messaging it sends
even to young people in the country that
you that destroy the character of
someone through a hoax or through lies
that due process means nothing that
equal justice means nothing is of course
ironically why Trump was elected he's
taking these slings and arrows and of
course we've got a year coming up here
where we can make a statement but in the
meantime more damage can be done if we
don't in fact and and they're you know
they're they're touching base at home
now right they're doing polls and this
is I think also Americans need to rise
up and say this is fundamentally wrong
work or not not going to allow this to
happen
ad nauseam from here on out and the only
way to do it is with their vote yeah
that's it Americans will do that at the
polls Tammy they will do that at the
polls we will indeed we've got a chance
for that thank God for the founder Sarah
Gregg thank you so much for the